we've had some great discussions in the
hall and a lot of rich interactions
among leaders throughout the day
so let me again thank thank all of the
ministers and the chiefs of defense
and your teams for joining us today
especially
my good friend ukraine's
minister of defense
minister reznikov
and his delegation it's great to see him
we're all coming away with a transparent
and shared understanding
of the challenge that the ukrainians
face
and i know that
we're all determined to help ukraine
win today and build strength for
tomorrow
the work that we've done together in
record time has made a huge difference
on the battlefield
president zielinski made that clear when
we met
sunday in key
and countries all around the world have
been stepping up to meet ukraine's
urgent needs
and i wanted to especially welcome a
major decision by our german host
as uh minister lombrecht announced just
today that germany will send ukraine
some 50 cheetah
anti-aircraft systems
and yesterday of course the british
government announced that it would
provide ukraine with additional
anti-aircraft capabilities as well
and today
canada announced that it will send
ukraine eight armored vehicles
and so that's important progress
we're seeing more every day
and i applaud all the countries that
have risen
and are rising
to meet this demand
but we don't have any time to waste
the briefings today laid out clearly why
the coming weeks will be
so crucial for ukraine
so we've got to move at the speed of war
and i know that all the leaders
leave today
more resolved than ever to support
ukraine
in his fight against russian aggression
and atrocities
and i know that
we're all determined to do even more
to better coordinate our efforts
so i was especially glad to hear general
walters encourage us all to make
more determined use of eucom's
coordination mechanism
now that to ensure that we continue to
build on our progress we're going to
extend this forum beyond today
i'm proud to announce that today's
gathering
will become a monthly contact group on
ukraine's
self-defense and the contact group will
be a vehicle for nations of good will to
intensify our efforts
and coordinate our assistance
and focus on winning today's fight
and the struggles to come
the monthly meetings may be in person
virtual or mixed
and they'll extend the transparency
the integration and the dialogue that we
saw today
and let me underscore another key point
we held an important session today on
the long-term support for ukraine's
defenses
including
what that will take from our defense
industrial bases
and that means dealing with the
tremendous demand that we're facing for
munitions
and weapons platforms
and giving our stunts support to ukraine
while also meeting our own requirements
and those of our allies and partners
but it also means redoubling our common
efforts to strengthen ukraine's military
for the long haul
and i look forward to to our discussions
in the contact group
and elsewhere about how to get that done
right
let me again thank all of the countries
who came together today
they've done crucial work
and they sent a powerful signal
we're going to build on today's progress
and continue to reach out to nations of
goodwill to help ukraine defend itself
and we'll continue working transparently
and urgently
with our allies and partners
and we'll continue pushing
to support and strengthen the ukrainian
military for the battles
ahead so we leave tonight strengthened
and so does ukraine
thank you and i'll be glad to take your
questions
thank you mr secretary our first
question today will come from sylvie
lantom afp
you have a microphone
thank you um mr secretary actually i
have a double question for you
moldova is stepping up its security
measures
after a series of explosions in a the
separatist region of trans nestle
do you think there is a risk of
spillover of the conflict to moldova
and my second question is after this big
meeting about arming ukraine
are you aren't you concerned that
putin may become
restless and
threaten again to use a nuclear weapon
well on
the issue of spillover to moldova
because of what we've seen here
the reporting of
recent
[Music]
uh violence we're still looking to the
cause of that but still
you know still doing an analysis there
so
not really sure what uh what that's all
about but that's something that we'll
we'll stay focused on
uh and certainly
we
don't want to see any spillover and and
uh and again
uh
it's important to make sure that we do
everything that we can
to ensure that ukraine is successful
and that's the best way to uh to address
that
uh and your second part of the question
there sylvie was
well you know you've heard uh
us say a number of times that uh that
kind of rhetoric is very dangerous and
unhelpful
um
nobody wants to see a nuclear war happen
happen it's a war that you know or all
sides lose and so
uh rattling of saber sabers and
and uh
you know dangerous rhetoric
is clearly unhelpful and something that
we won't engage in
our next question goes to
suzanne
gelhardt from zdf
mr secretary what military aid do you
now expect from the german government
and do you think the delivery of jeopard
tanks is sufficient in your opinion
you mean cheetahs which is what the yeah
um let me just say that
and i think you've probably heard me say
this before as i visited germany
i consider germany to be a great friend
and an ally
uh and uh you know we've served uh i've
served in germany as a as an officer and
and worked with german forces and
and i it's always been a real pleasure
to uh
to work alongside our german partners
here
now i think it's it's significant that
you know germany announced that it was
going to provide 50 cheetah systems i
think those systems will provide real
capability to for ukraine and in terms
of
what else germany will do going forward
again that's uh that's a sovereign
decision one that you're that the german
leadership will make and i don't want to
speculate on that i i just believe that
just based upon everything that i've
seen
in my interaction with the minister of
defense and how intently she's been
focused on making sure that she can do
everything that she can to help and work
alongside her partners and allies
that she'll continue to look for ways to
be
to be
uh relevant and and provide uh
uh good capability to the ukrainians as
they continue to uh to prosecute this
fight
next question goes to john is me new
york times
mr secretary uh yesterday you mentioned
that one of the united states goals in
ukraine now was to see russia weakened
can you explain more fully what that
means and specifically
what do you want to weaken and how you
would measure success in that regard
yeah john so i i think we've been pretty
clear from from the outset
we do want to make it harder for russia
to
threaten its neighbors and
and leave them less able to do that now
if you look at what's transpired here
in this 62 days or so that
that ukraine and russia have been
have been involved in this struggle here
russia has uh in terms of its land
forces the land forces have been
attributed in a very significant way
casualties are
are are pretty substantial they've lost
a lot of a lot of equipment
they've used a lot of precision guided
munitions
they've lost a major surface combatant
and so they are in fact in terms of
military capability weaker than when
they started and you know john it'll be
harder for them for them to replace some
of this capability as they go forward
because of the sanctions and the trade
restrictions that have been placed on
them and and so
we would like to make sure again
that they don't have the same type of
capability
to bully their neighbors that we that we
saw at the outset of this of this
conflict